je suis la poêle plein de cacao en train
de me balader dans la cour tous nus ça
vous est déjà arrivé à l'antenne
quelques uns ici d'avoir un problème et
vous signale gérer des annonces en
plateau dans un bouchon des choses comme
ça battu à six alors quoi abattons
périphérique wii a raconté ici mais
c'est la chasse
je suis je vais j'ai dîné avec la manne
ron des divertissements de france 3
l'époque jeudi sur france 3 et je vais
assez loin de chez moi
tryba est donc voilà qu'on mange et je
suis dans la voiture je suis sur la
route et je sens que j'ai un mal au
ventre mais vous savez pouvez pas savoir
et là je suis sur le périphérique ou
périphériques c'est comme auto et je
regarde la porte où je suis et je me dis
les popotes frère on n'y arrive pas on
est mort et là je suis sur le périph et
je lâche pas on lâche tout je suis dans
stress total c'est chaud partout mais je
vous le dit ça au monde dans le dos ça
vous avez voulu et vous l'avez voulue et
j'avais des sièges en alcantara
autant vous dire que ça absorbe je vous
lis je suis tellement mal que je me
garde comme ça je me met en travers de
la route quand j'arrive chez moi et je
rentre à la maison et j'avais toute une
cour à traverser mais qu'est ce que je
fais j'enlève tous mes amis et je les
jette dans une poubelle ça veut dire je
suis la poêle plein de kaka
en train de me balader dans la cour tous
nus je rencontre une personne qui était
dans l'immeuble et qui me voile ont tous
lu comme ça je rentre à la maison je
suis à poils bruns de kaka et la madoff
je me dis bah tu étais où j'ai vendu la
voiture à camille combal
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]